-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
I'm Jimmy Fallon,
anchoring hour 30
of NBC's election-night
coverage.
Come on. It's 2020.
Did you really think last night
would end up wrapped up
with a neat little bow?
Seriously, today, it felt like
waking up with a hangover,
then realizing
you're still at the bar.
"What time is it?"
What a long, emotional, and
confusing ride this has been.
It's like a Matthew McConaughey
car commercial that won't end.
Meanwhile, you think
you're stressed.
Imagine how
President Trump feels.
In two months,
he's either getting
inaugurated or incarcerated.
It was a crazy night.
Here's what most people heard
right before they went to bed.
-Too close to call.
-Yeah, the one thing we know for
sure is, no more polls.
That's it. Done, okay?
No more polls, alright?
From now on, the only time
Americans want to hear
about a poll is if
they're talking about Santa
or strippers.
♪♪
Yep, today, pollsters saw
a different blue wave
right as they were slowly
walking into the ocean.
At this point,
I'd rather hear predictions from
the guy trying to guess my
weight at a carnival.
Pollsters were basically us
when we really think
we've nailed a parallel park but
then get out of the car
and see we're about
14 feet from the curb.
It's like, "Honey, look out.
You don't want to scrape
the bottom of the do--
Oh, actually, well,
we could fit a Le Car
between where we parked
and where the..."
-Le Car.
[ Laughter ]
I knew you'd laugh at "Le Car."
From now on,
when you release a poll,
just say both candidates
are tied
with a margin of error of 100.
As we speak, some states are
still tallying the votes.
Somehow, Chuck E. Cheese
can count a million tickets
on the spot, and we still can't
count the votes in three days?
I can't take
the suspense anymore.
My stress eating has gone from
brownies to ice cream
to just pouring raw cake mix
down my throat.
Yep, the race is
still too close to call.
Apparently,
a lot of voters looked at
90,000 COVID cases a day
and thought,
"Sure, I can do
four more years of this."
Experts still can't believe
the race is this tight.
Apparently, people were voting
based on which candidate
they want to drink bleach with.
But one of the big stars of
the election night
was America's sweetheart
and MSNBC political
correspondent Steve Kornacki,
who is on our show this evening.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guy was working the touch-screen
map like a magician.
All night long, he was shown on
the "Kornacki Cam."
You see that?
MSNBC basically treated him like
a panda that was about to
give birth.
Last night was incredibly tense,
and you could tell
the newscasters were feeling it.
Even CNN's graphics guy,
who does the banner
at the bottom of the screen,
was stressed out.
Take a look at this.
-And when Florida's close, it
comes down to the I-4 corridor.
-But a tremendous amount of
Democratic vote
are still outstanding at...
-You know, that's nearly
30 points there -- 28 points.
-That puts him at
17,000, 18,000 votes.
-With this
wild and different 2020,
mail-in voting,
in-person early voting.
If he saw this and,
say, it's past midnight...
The question is,
is that just the early votes
or are there votes?
Wayne County...
-And they are going to
count ballots
that come in postmarked
by Election Day.
-It was no longer off the map,
like they thought it was
after 2016.
-And, so, what I'm
trying to do is
identify where, specifically,
in this county...
-He's moving to Belgium.
He's moving to Belgium.
Well, very early this morning,
Biden spoke to a drive-in crowd
in Wilmington, Delaware, and he
told us that we need patience.
But I'm not sure it's
one of America's strengths.
I mean, if a TikTok video isn't
fun in the first 3 seconds,
we're like, "Ah, next."
Yeah, we just have to be
patient in a country
that literally invented
a Domino's tracker
so we know exactly
when our pizza will arrive.
Like, "It's in the oven, honey!
It's in the oven!
He's almost here!
Honey, wave to him.
Make sure he knows it's us."
But this is very interesting.
Joe Biden actually
got more votes
than any other candidate
in history.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
So, once again,
how is this even close?
Meanwhile, Trump spoke
from The White House
early this morning,
and he seemed upset
that the results weren't
immediately called in his favor.
Watch this.
-We were getting ready
for a big celebration.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We were winning everything.
And, all of a sudden,
it was just called off.
Literally, we were just all
set to get outside
and just celebrate something
that was so beautiful, so good.
-Aww. That's too bad.
I'd hate for the election to get
in the way of a good party.
Yeah, Trump also lashed out at
the voting process
and made a pretty bold claim.
Take a look at this.
-This is a fraud
on the American public.
This is an embarrassment
to our country.
We were getting ready to win
this election.
Frankly, we did win
-Yeah. If you're keeping track,
in the same speech,
Trump claimed the election was
a fraud and an embarrassment
and then declared victory.
I don't think
we should correct Trump.
Just nod along,
put him in a fake White House,
and let him spend
the next four years
thinking he's in charge.
Who cares, right?
Well, as you can might expect,
Trump has been
tweeting a lot today, and you
could tell he's getting worried,
because one of his posts said...
Dude, they're not finding votes.
They're counting them.
Because no one wanted to
leave the house
because there's a pandemic!
Gosh!
Trump's getting close to
being like,
"Okay, forget about the votes.
Let's measure
this thing in retweets."
Oh, and before
we go any further,
here's some extremely important
election news.
-Voters in New Jersey
have passed
a constitutional amendment
legalizing
recreational marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right --
weed is legal in New Jersey.
You just know there's
already guy walking around
in a tie-dye track suit.
He's like, "Excuse me.
You guys like, uh...
You guys like Phish?
You like the Phish?
Like the Phish.
May wake up with a fish
in your bed. A fish."
♪♪
Listen, when you're home to
the Jets and Giants,
you got to make drugs legal.
Now that weed is legal,
New Yorkers
driving into New Jersey
are gonna go from
rolling their windows up
to rolling them down.
It's like, "Ahh!"
And this makes sense.
Once Jersey legalized weed,
they also voted to put a Wawa
on their state flag.
So far, legalized weed
has been a little rough.
Every time the mob buries
a snitch, they forget where.
But if you think legal weed
is a big deal,
just listen to what Oregon did.
-Oregon voters passing measure
to decriminalize
small amounts of cocaine,
heroin, and other drugs.
-I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
A small amount of heroin?
Who is only doing
a small amount --
Show of hands --
does anyone know someone
who casually does heroin?
Just a little bit?
"I just do it on the weekends.
Yeah, I do it sometimes
when I drink."
I do heroin -- a little bit."
And, finally, earlier today,
Gap tried to send
a message of unity over Twitter
by posting a short video of a
red-and-blue hoodie
with the caption...
Kind of weird, right?
Trying to bring
the country together
when your name is The Gap.